Der Rasenfunk. Kurzpass. Was ist los in Portugals Liga? Diese Frage haben wir noch nicht beantwortet im Rasenfunk. Beste Zeit wird's mal. Wir sprechen darüber mit Marc Wiese, der für Sport digital die portugiesische Liga verfolgt. Marc, sagen wir sehr herzlich Grüßt. Hi. Heute sprechen wir mal nicht über den HSV oder nicht über die Bundesliga, so wie in der Schlusskonferenz, wo du ja auch schon zweimal zu Gast warst. Heute sprechen wir mal über Portugal. Ich mich auch. Ja, vielen Dank, dass du diese Einladung angenommen hast, denn Portugals Liga ist so ein bisschen häufig unter dem Radar. Und die Frage können wir jetzt ja dann heute auch klären, ob zu Recht oder zu Unrecht. Wir beginnen auch ganz einfach wie immer, dass wir einfach mal auf die Tabelle gucken. Und da sehe ich von oben Benfica Lisbon grüßen zwei Punkte vor dem FC Porto. Und dazu muss man wissen, die beiden haben jetzt gegeneinander gespielt, am Samstag. Und Benfica hat trotz Unterzahl hinten raus mit 2 zu 1 dieses Spiel gegen Porto gewonnen. Stehen die denn zu Recht zwei Punkte vor dem Tabellen 2?
Ja, also jetzt angesichts dieses Spiels, was natürlich das Spiel der Spiele überhaupt jetzt in Portugal war, stehen sie da natürlich zu Recht. Das war natürlich ein sehr knappes Spiel. Es hat aber auch ganz gut die Situation dieser beiden Teams aufgezeigt, denn Benfica hat in diesem Spiel und das finde ich sieht man auch so ein bisschen über die gesamte Saison so ein bisschen den größeren Willen, so ein bisschen mehr Power. Sie sind ein sehr junges Team, sehr hungrig. Da werden wir auch noch zu kommen gleich. Und das hat sich auch in diesem Spiel gezeigt. Also da war sehr viel Selbstvertrauen irgendwie mit drin, sehr viel Lust auch auf dieses Spiel. Das, was natürlich bei Porto auch aufgrund der Brisanz das Spiel spielst, da war. Aber sie haben eben mit Spielern wie natürlich Joao Feliz und Ruben Dias und Ferro, auch die beiden Innenverteidiger, so viel junges Blut da drin. Das hat wirklich Spaß gemacht, da zuzusehen und auch eine unglaubliche Offensivpower. Und insgesamt hat Porto wahrscheinlich ein Tick mehr individuelle Klasse, aber schwächelt dann doch in diesem Jahr in einigen Spielen. Und jetzt konkret in dem Spiel, fand ich, dass Benfica da fußballerisch ein bisschen klarer, ein bisschen zielstrebiger nach vorne aufgetreten ist und ein bisschen mehr Herz gespielt hat. Und deswegen, klar, es wurde hinten raus, schon knapp dann mit dem Platzverweis und auch ein paar Gelegenheiten für Porto. Aber das war nicht unverdient und deswegen stehen sie da auch nicht unverdient oben an der Spitze.
Also Benfica, Offensive ist da auf jeden Fall das Zauberwort. 66 Tore in 24 Spielen, insgesamt in allen Pflichtspielen haben sie 86 Tore in 42 Spielen gemacht. Also das ist locker über einen Zwei-Tore-Schnitt. Wobei man dazu auch sagen muss, über ein Ergebnis bin ich gestolpert. Mitte Februar ein 10 zu 0 gegen National, die nicht irgendwie abgeschlagen auf dem Tabellenplatz ganz hinten in der Liga liegen, sondern auf Tabellenplatz 12. Was war denn da los?
Ja, unfassbar. Also ich habe das Spiel auch nicht über 90 Minuten gesehen, aber es hat dann auch schon gereicht, sich die 10 Tore anzugucken.
Waren ja dann auch wahrscheinlich drei Minuten.
Also das beschreibt dann auch noch mal sehr gut das oder untermalt das noch mal sehr gut, was ich gerade gesagt habe. Diese unglaubliche Lust, also wenn du gegen einen Aufsteiger spielst und schon, weiß nicht, 6-7-0 führst, dann noch weiter zu machen und einfach da das Maximum rauszuholen, das ja, das beschreibt sehr gut das Denken von diesen Spielern und was sie auch diese Saison erreichen wollen. Sie sind jetzt letzte Saison das erste Mal nach ein paar Jahren wieder nicht Meister geworden. Sie sind ja 2014 bis 2017 vier Mal in Folge Meister gewesen. Jetzt hat Porto letztes Jahr den Titel geholt, auch relativ klar mit sieben Punkten Vorsprung. Und ich glaube einfach in dieser Mannschaft ist ein Spirit drin. Die haben unfassbar Lust auf diesen Titel. Die wollen sich den unbedingt zurückholen.
Und sie haben ja auch einen neuen Trainer seit Anfang oder Mitte Januar. Man hat Bruno Lage, der bestimmt nicht so ausgesprochen wird, jetzt Bruno Larsch verpflichtet, nachdem Rui Vitoria nicht mehr Trainer sein durfte, sein konnte, kannst du mich kurz ins Boot holen? Das ist peinlicherweise an mir vorbeigegangen. Wie hat dieser Trainerwechsel da stattgefunden?
Ja, also diese Unzufriedenheit bei Benfica war so schon so ein bisschen nach dem verpassten Titel letztes Jahr da und das wurde dann noch verstärkt durch das Ausscheiden in der Champions League und auch dem Fakt, dass man nach einem 0 zu 2 bei Porto Immonense, da ist er dann rausgeflogen, sieben Punkte Rückstand auf Porto hatte und da war es dann schon Anfang November richtig eng für ihn und dann gab es drei Pflichtspielniederlagen in Folge und dann haben die Fans natürlich dann auch schon den Rauswurf gefordert und deswegen das hat sich alles so ein bisschen entwickelt und ja jetzt unter Bruno Larsch läuft es halt richtig gut, ne, also neun Spiele gewonnen und das mit unfassbaren 35 zu 6 Toren. Natürlich schlägt da dieses 10-0 gegen National auch ordentlich zu Buche, aber sie haben eben auch gegen Porto und Sporting gewonnen und das ist eben dann auch schon eine Ansage, ne?
Absolut, Porto eben jetzt, da werden zwei, das habe ich schon angesprochen, Sporting auf Platz 4, über die werden wir denke ich noch sprechen. Wir müssen aber auch noch sprechen über den Top-Tor-Schützen bei Benfica, das ist nicht eben zum Beispiel der vorhin schon erwähnte Joao Felix, der auch in der Talente des Weltfußballs Folge angesprochen wurde. Nein, es ist ein alter Bekannter, Haris Seferovic. Er lebt seinen zweiten, dritten, vierten, keine Ahnung, Frühling. So alt ist er eigentlich noch gar nicht, aber gefühlt ist er schon ewig im Fußball mit dabei. Führt die Torschützenliste an mit 15 Treffern und 5 Assists hat er auch noch.
Ja, also unfassbar. Ich war ehrlich gesagt immer ein Fan von ihm als Spielertyp. Er war ja nicht immer so der einfachste Charakter auch in seiner Frankfurter Zeit. Ich glaube persönlich, dass er ein Spieler ist, der unglaublich von einer gewissen Wertschätzung zehrt. Ich glaube, das ist einfach was, was er braucht und die bekommt er bei Benfica. Er hat auch letzte Saison, glaube ich, schon 8 Tore gemacht. Er hat auch schon eine ganz gute Einstandssaison gehabt. Diese sechs Vorlagen zu diesen 15 Toren, er ist unglaublich abgebrüht vor dem Tor, sowohl mit links, mit rechts als auch mit dem Kopf, diese sechs Vorlagen dazu zeigen, auch dass er, wenn er sich wohlfühlt, auch echt für die Mannschaft da ist, dass er Mannschaftsdämlich spielt, dass er sich in jeden Zweikampf wirft. Vielleicht hat er diese Wertschätzung bei Frankfurt über die gesamte Zeit nicht genug bekommen. Man ist da aber auch nicht tief genug drin. Man weiß auch nicht, wie das mit den einzelnen Trainern dann sich bei ihm gestaltet hat. Aber ja, es passt vieles zusammen bei ihm. Und man sieht, wenn er sich wohlfühlt, dann ist er ein Stürmer, der absolut internationales Niveau hat.
Und profitiert offenbar von einem Pizzi, der noch nie so viele Vorlagen in seiner gesamten Karriere hatte. Also der hat mal ganz früher bei Atletico gespielt, dann Deportivo La Caronia, Espanyol, Barcelona. Und dann kam schon 2014, 2015 der Wechsel zu Benfica seit dem Spieltader und hat 13 Vorlagen in der Saison gegeben, zusätzlich zu noch mal acht Toren.
Ja, ja, also Pizzi ist da sicherlich auch eine entscheidende Figur, neben Seferovic und Feliz. Also über die geht offensiv eigentlich alles. Pizzi ist auch echt ein Spielmacher, wie er im Buch steht. So auch schlägt richtig gute Flanken, auch ein gutes Verhalten im Pressing. Das ist auch eine Sache, die ihn irgendwie ausmacht. Ja, also der mit seinen 29 Jahren erlebt auch noch mal eine richtig gute Zeit momentan.
Das sieht alles sehr, sehr gut aus und dem gegenüber steht dann aber, du hast es vorhin schon erwähnt, das Ausschalten in der Champions League. Da erinnern wir uns ja auch noch gut an die Gruppe. Da waren ja die Bayern mit dabei und Ajax und die Bayern konnten da weiterkommen. Und jetzt auch ganz frisch quasi noch in der Europa League ein 0 zu 1. Sagt das was aus über den Wettbewerb, die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der portugiesischen Liga? Überbewerte ich da Einzelphänomene. Wie würdest du das einordnen?
Also ich habe jetzt Benfica in der Europa League noch nicht so verfolgt diese Saison. Weil ich dann auch nicht Lust habe, immer alles zu gucken.
Es ist in Ordnung, du musst dich nicht rechtfertigen.
Europa League ist ja auch nicht dein Lieblingswettbewerb.
Wobei die Eintracht arbeitet gerade dran, dass ich, also wir zwei haben diese Aufnahme hier nach hinten verschoben. So ehrlich können wir das sein am Donnerstagabend, als wir gesehen haben, da spielt er die Eintracht gegen Inter.
Und Eintracht Inter lässt man sich dann natürlich nicht entgegen.
Genau, aber Leverkusen-Krasnodar, da gebe ich zu, habe ich auch noch mit einem Auge getroffen.
Ja, also weiß ich nicht, ob ihre Einstellung da zu der Europa League nicht groß genug ist, ob vielleicht, wie du jetzt auch das ansprichst, die Liga NOSCH da nicht das Format hat, was ich eigentlich nicht glaube, weil sie dann ja doch auch in der Europa League Gegner haben, die jetzt, na ja, sagen wir mal, jetzt nicht viel besser als die Top 6, Top 7 in Portugal sind. Deswegen kann ich dir das jetzt auch nicht so direkt erklären, aber vielleicht ist es einfach auch dieser Fakt, was wir gerade auch eben auch schon gesagt haben, sie haben einfach Lust, dieses Jahr diese Meisterschaft zu holen. Und ja, ich glaube schon, dass da auch insgesamt der Fokus drauf liegt.
Das könnte natürlich sein, aber diese Frage der internationalen Vergleichbarkeit, die kann man ja auch wunderbar am FC Porto nochmal durchdeklinieren, der eben auf Tabellenplatz 2 steht, wie schon angesprochen, eben erst mit dieser Niederlage gegen Benfica jetzt abgerutscht ist am vergangenen Wochenende, aber unter der Woche in einem aussehenerregenden Spiel mit 3 zu 1 nach Verlängerung gegen die Roma gewonnen hat. Wie glaubst du denn, sind da denn die Prioritäten verteilt zwischen internationaler Wettbewerb und Meisterschaft?
Boah, das ist auch echt schwierig zu sagen. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass jetzt gerade nach diesem Spiel gegen die Roma, dass die schon ein bisschen mehr vielleicht auf die Champions League gucken. Das kommt jetzt sicherlich auch darauf an, wen sie kriegen. Ich meine, wenn sie jetzt Juve kriegen, wenn sie Liverpool, man weiß ja nicht, wer jetzt weiterkommt. Aber wenn sie jetzt die ganz Großen da kriegen, dann, ja, weiß nicht, dann werden sie vielleicht sich sagen, gut, Meisterschaft hat Bio. Wenn es jetzt eine Mannschaft wird, sie sich schlagen können, kann ich mir schon gut vorstellen. Also so ein Champions League Halbfinale ist natürlich äußerst reizvoll. Seit 2004 haben sie ja, glaube ich, die Champions League geholt. Sind sie, glaube ich, auch nicht mehr so weit gekommen. Von daher ist das sicherlich ein sehr großer Anreiz. Und ja, das wird auch spannend zu sehen sein, wie sich das dann auf die Liga auswirkt. Ich meine, Benfica kann sich da jetzt voll und ganz darauf konzentrieren. Weiß man nicht auch jetzt, wie sich dieser Sieg gegen Roma dann auswirkt. Gibt es, ist es eher der Vorteil, durch das Selbstvertrauen treten sie jetzt auch in der Liga nosch damit einen richtig breiten Post auf. Oder ist es vielleicht dann der fehlende Fokus auf die Meisterschaft, der sich dann da, ja, der dann da ausschlaggebend ist. Also das ist wirklich sehr schwer zu sagen. Deswegen ist es ein sehr enger Titelkampf. Das Momentum spricht natürlich ein bisschen für Benfica. Aber gut, auch so eine junge Truppe macht mal irgendwie Fehler. Vielleicht werden da jetzt auch schon die nächsten beiden Spiele vorencheinend. Vor allem Benfica, die spielen gegen Berlin Lenzasch und Moray Renze. Gegen die hat man in der Hinrunde verloren. Werden diese beiden gewonnen und zeigen sie dann keine Schwäche gegen die Kleinen. Würde ich sagen, Benfica macht das diese Saison. Aber es ist schwer zu sagen. Also Porto ist jetzt auch keine Mannschaft, die sich von ein paar Unentschieden, die sie in letzter Zeit mal hatten, aus der Ruhe bringen lässt. Und jetzt gerade dieser Erfolg in der Champions League wird noch mal Auftrieb geben. Also das wird richtig spannend. Und es kann sein, dass es die erste Meisterschaft seit 2015, 16 wird, die bis zum Schluss richtig spannend ist. Damals war das bis zum letzten Spiel dazwischen Benfica und Sporting auch noch. Das heißt, ein Stadt-Duell quasi um die Meisterschaft. Ja, also da können sich die Fans in Portugal und alle, die die Liga noch verfolgen, dieses Jahr sicher auf ein spannendes Meisterschaftsfinal freuen.
Ja, es ist kein Zufall, dass wir miteinander sprechen und jetzt über Portugal sprechen. So viel sei an dieser Stelle verraten. Wenn ich mir jetzt den FC Porto angucke, dann sehe ich da im Tor Ika Kasiya, 37 Jahre alt. Ich sehe Maxi Pereira, der ist 34. Ich sehe Pepe, der ist 36. Und wenn ich das dann alles runterbreche, dann sehe ich Porto im Schnitt zwei Jahre älter als Benfica. Ist das auch der größte Unterschied zwischen den beiden oder unterscheidet die beiden auch in der Spielanlage was?
Ja, also das sieht man schon, gerade diese Reife. Porto ist eine Mannschaft, die spielt sehr reif. Die haben Vertrauen in ihre Stärke. Die halten den Ball auch mal länger in den eigenen Reihen, während es bei Benfica dann doch relativ schnell und zügig Richtung Tor geht. Das ist eben dieser Esprit, den Benfica dann hat. Die haben einfach einfach unglaubliche Lust, Tore zu erzielen und das tun sie auch. Und bei Porto muss man ja sagen, sie haben jetzt diese Saison noch gar nicht mal so viele Tore geschossen. Jetzt muss ich gerade mal gucken.
48.
48, siehst du, das ist 48 Tore zu 66 bei Benfica. Da spielt natürlich auch sicherlich eine Rolle die Langzeitverletzung von Abu Bakr. Das ist natürlich eine Riesen-Säule, die ihn da wegbricht. Aber gut, mit Marega haben sie jetzt auch nicht den schlechtesten Go-Getter, wobei der auch zwischenzeitlich verletzt war. Tikino Suarez macht das jetzt ganz gut in den letzten Spielen, hat er jetzt auch in der Champions League getroffen. Aber ja, letzte Saison haben sie mit Abu Bakr 82 Tore erzielt, wo er an 19 davon beteiligt war. Ja, diese Saison ist es dann eher so, dass es viele verschiedene sind, die die Tore machen, was ja auch irgendwie was Positives hat. Aber mit ihm ist natürlich deutlich mehr Torgefahr und Wucht irgendwie drin. Ja, deswegen, die Mannschaften, gegen die Porto spielt, sind natürlich sehr, sehr auf ihre Defensive bedacht und Porto, ja, ist dann vielleicht in einigen Spielen nicht so zielspielig Richtung Tor und braucht dann mal länger, bis sie sich ihre Chancen rausspielen. Und deswegen sind jetzt auch in der Vergangenheit einige Unentschieden zustande gekommen, auch teilweise glücklich. Ich denke da jetzt vor allem an ein Spiel gegen Moderenze, wo sie wirklich, ja, eigentlich sogar fast die unterlegendere Mannschaft waren und dann haben sie noch in der Nachspielzeit ein Tor gemacht. Weil sie haben so ein paar Spiele diese Saison drin, wo sie nachlässig sind. Aber wie gesagt, ich würde da jetzt noch nicht auf irgendwas in Richtung Meisterschaft schließen. Das ist zum Ende ganz spannend.
Ne, das muss man jetzt ja auch noch nicht machen. Zehn Spieltageverschluss. Das ist ja ähnlich wie in der Bundesliga. Da muss man jetzt auch noch nicht so tun, als wäre jetzt schon alles entschieden. Wer sind denn so die entscheidenden Spieler bei Porto jetzt jenseits von den Sturmreihen, die du ja jetzt schon mit Abu Bakr und eben Marega die entscheidenden Spieler genannt hast?
Ja, also offensiv haben wir jetzt gerade darüber geredet. Marega Sordic ist eigentlich klar. Man muss aber sagen, das Prunkstück in dieser Saison von Porto ist ganz klar die Defensive. Das ist überragend gut, was sie da machen. Sie haben nur 14 Gegentore kassiert, 14 Spiele ohne Gegentor. Also Kassias auf seine alten Tage auch noch der Torwart in Liga NOSCH, der die meisten Spiele ohne Gegentor hatte.
Kriegt auch die wenigsten Schüsse tatsächlich gegen sich. 8,7 pro Spiel. Das ist auch wirklich sehr wenig, muss man sagen.
Genau, also die Verteidigung ist da schon entscheidend. Also diese 14 Spiele ohne Gegentore sind übrigens auch mehr als die Hälfte der Saison. Das muss man sich auch mal vergegenfertigen. Das ist schon echt stark, was die da machen. Und hier muss man zum ersten, finde ich, erst mal nennen, bevor man auf das große Innenverteidiger-Talent kommt, was sie bei sich haben, muss man auf Felipe gucken. Denn der ist nämlich der Dauerbrenner. Der hat fast jedes Spiel gemacht, war schon letzte Saison Stammspieler. Also der ist unfassbar beständig, jetzt schon über eine lange Zeit. Und Eda Militao ist natürlich eins der größten Innenverteidiger-Talente überhaupt. Laut Transfermarkt hat er auch den größten Marktwert in der gesamten Liga. Seine Stärken hat er ganz klar in der Luft. Also es ist eigentlich, was Kopfbälle angeht, unüberwindbar, obwohl er glaube ich selbst nur 1,85 groß ist. Er hat ein richtig gutes Stellungsspiel, Zweikampf. Also es ist alles eigentlich vorhanden bei ihm. Und deswegen gibt es ja jetzt auch schon die Gerüchte um Real Madrid. Die Ausstiegsklausel liegt bei ihm glaube ich bei 75 Millionen Euro. Cassias hat ihn jetzt auch letztens noch mal explizit gelobt im gleichen Satz, aber dann natürlich auch gesagt, dass er es mal bloß bleiben lassen soll. Er hat noch so ein bisschen Probleme mit der Disziplin. Er war letztens suspendiert, weil er vor einem wichtigen Spiel eine Partynacht sich hat leisten können, aus seiner Sicht. Danach saß er dann gegen Benfica auf der Bank. Ich glaube allerdings jetzt so nach der Leistung von Pepe gegen Benfica, gut jetzt gestern war das ganz ordentlich, aber ich glaube schon, dass das Eder Militao dann auch wieder in der Innenverteidigung spielen wird. Jetzt spielen sie gegen Ferenze, das ist nicht das allerschwerste Spiel gegen den Letzten, aber er ist natürlich ein Riesentalent und da kann man schon auch gespannt sein, was dann in Zukunft aus ihm wird.
21 Jahre alt, kommt aus Brasilien und ist eben erst zu dieser Saison von São Paulo zum FC Porto gewechselt, also noch ganz frisch in der Liga für eine kolportierte Ablösesumme von irgendwas zwischen 7 Millionen und ein bisschen mehr Guthandgelder und so weiter, aber das rechnen wir ja nirgendwo mit rein, weil wir da nichts zu wissen können. Also da hat Porto einen richtig guten Griff gemacht und das könnte dann auch der Unterschied zu Benfica sein, wenn man sich eben die defensiv-freie anguckt mit diesen 14 Gegentreffern nach 24 Spielen. Das ist schon einfach. Das ist schon einfach gut, so muss man sagen. Auch wenn Porto jetzt in den letzten Spielen ein paar Punkte hat liegen lassen, zwei unentschieden, dann die Niederlage, aber es sind ja nur zwei Punkte Rückstand. Was tut sich denn dahinter? Zum Beispiel bei Braga, die liegen auf Tabellenplatz 3, haben 5 Punkte Rückstand auf 2, 7 Punkte Rückstand auf den Tabellenführer Benfica. Sich aber so ein bisschen jetzt durch zwei Niederlagen in den letzten drei Ligaspielen die Chance verspielt, da irgendwie noch mit einzugreifen? Oder würdest du die noch mit reinnehmen in den Meisterschaftskampf?
Na, ich glaube es eher nicht. Dafür sind Benfica und Porto zu stark, auch qualitativ in der Breite und auch in der Tiefe besser. Trotzdem muss man auch schon den Hut davor ziehen, was Braga diese Saison wieder hinlegt. Die waren letzte Saison schon richtig stark. Also punktemäßig war das, glaube ich, die beste Saison der Vereinsgeschichte mit 75. In dieser Saison knüpfen sie auf jeden Fall absolut daran an. Und ich glaube Platz 3 vor Sporting, das wäre schon ein Erfolg. Letztes Mal sind sie Dritter geworden, 2012. Mehr glaube ich nicht, dass das da drin ist. Aber das ist, glaube ich, auch erst mal noch nicht ihr Anspruch. Also Platz 3, wie gesagt, das wäre schon ein Erfolg. Die letzten Jahre waren sie eigentlich auch immer unter den Top 4, aber meistens eben Vierter geworden. Haben ja auch immer Euroleague dann auch gespielt. In Portugal ist es ja so, dass der Dritte und Vierte in erst mal in die Quali gehen. Haben sich jetzt aber in Europa noch nicht so erfolgreich gezeigt. Also meistens sind sie da in der Quali beziehungsweise in der Gruppenphase raus. Zuletzt richtig erfolgreich waren sie da 15, 16. Da haben sie es ins Viertelfinale geschafft, dann gegen Schachtio raus. In der Liga geben sie sich eigentlich so gegen die kleineren Teams überhaupt keine Blöße. Also sie haben in dieser Saison eigentlich nur gegen die Großen verloren, also gegen Porto, Benfica und Sporting und noch eine Niederlage gegen Berlin-Nensisch. Ja, aber das zeigt dann eben auch das. Also wenn sie gegen genau diese Mannschaften dann immer doch auch relativ deutlich verlieren, dann zeigt das, dass dieser Schritt Richtung Champions League beziehungsweise ein Erzunehmender Meisterschaftskonkurrent zu werden, ja, dass der eben noch fehlt.
Und das scheint ja auch so ein bisschen zermittiert zu sein. Also Benfica, Porto, die gehen vorne mit daran. Dann ist eigentlich Sporting noch so traditionell eher auf Platz 3. Und dann eben Braga. Du hast es ja angesprochen. Also es ist ja völlig grotesk, wenn man sich mal anguckt, die letzten Platzierungen von Braga, die waren fast immer viertel. Also da konntest du fast immer mit planen, mit der höchste Ausreißer nach oben war eben mal 2009, 2010. Da wurde man Zweiter und der tiefste nach unten war, dass man Achter wurde. Also ich weiß nicht, was eine graue Maus in diesem Regionen, das ist ja dann nicht mehr grau. Aber sagt dir auch ein bisschen was über die Liga aus, oder?
Ja, also klar, wir reden hier über die Premier Liga, die Liga NOSCH. Das ist keine der Top-Ligen. Sie ist eine der Ligen, die sich dahinter einreiht, also in der zweiten Riege quasi. Ich finde, man kann das ganz gut vergleichen, wahrscheinlich so wie die holländische Liga ungefähr. Wobei wahrscheinlich bist du in der Spitze eben sogar noch mal ein bisschen besser besetzt als Holland. Aber ich finde es vergleichbar, weil du eben auch einige richtig coole Talente mit drin hast. Aber dann doch auch schon, ich sage jetzt mal, so ein Sonntagnachmittagsspiel zwischen Tsjabes und Feydenkse, das ist nichts für Feinschmecker. Das ist dann doch auch schon mal ein bisschen schwerer Fußballkost. Aber man kann sich die Liga schon gut angucken. Ich mache das jetzt eine Weile und da sind schon auch immer sehr interessante Spiele dabei. Und wir kommen ja gleich vielleicht auch noch auf ein paar Überraschungs-Mannschaften zu sprechen. Da sind einige Teams auch dabei, die ich schon auch interessant finde, die jetzt nicht in den Top-Mannschaften in Portugal sind. Also, das kann man sich schon angucken.
Ja, ich meine, du hast da natürlich jetzt gleich schon die krassesten Beispiele rausgenommen. Also, Tsjabes und Ference. Tsjabes Vorletzter mit 17 Toren nach 24 Spielen, Ference Letzter mit 14 Toren nach 24 Spielen. Und getoppt werden beide noch von Maritimo, die aktuell auf dem 15. Platz liegen, einem vor dem Relegationsplatz mit 13 Treffer nach 24 Spielen. Jaja, klar, so schafft es dann irgendwie trotzdem noch, 24 Punkte zu kriegen. Also, da ist ein 1-Punkt-Schnitt mit 13 erzieheten Toren nach 24 Spielen, da kann man auch seinen Hut von ziehen. Aber wenn wir sowieso gerade so ein bisschen bei diesem Metathema sind, wie würdest du denn den Fußball, der in der portugiesischen Liga gespielt wird, beschreiben?
Also, das muss man eigentlich unterteilen. Also, die Top-Teams sind da schon klar dominierend. Das ist dann auch schon, das kann man dann auch schon vergleichen. Ich weiß nicht, wenn man in der Bundesliga Bayern gegen Freiburg sieht, so ist das auch, wenn Porto oder Benfica gegen Avis oder Stubal spielen. Und bei Braga ist es eigentlich ähnlich. Natürlich nicht mit der Dominanz. Also, da sind eben auch schon mal Spiele drin, die knapper sind. Aber grundsätzlich, man kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass ein bestimmter Fußball in Portugal gespielt wird. Also, das ist eigentlich, wie du es in jeder Liga irgendwie hast, je nach Situation der einzelnen Teams spielen sie eben den Fußball. Also, eine Mannschaft wie Boa Vista ist eigentlich so die klassische Mannschaft, die, ja, sagen wir mal, den Abstiegskampf spielt und den Minimalisten-Fußball, die kaum irgendwas zulassen, aber auch selber eigentlich relativ wenig Tore schießen und dann meist irgendwie mit einem 1 zu 0 gewinnt. Ja, deswegen, man kann gar nicht jetzt da irgendwie etwas Allgemeines sagen. Aber, ja, diese Liga, wie gesagt, man kann sich das schon anschauen, aber es ist natürlich nicht die fußballerisch attraktivste Liga.
Ja, dafür vielleicht die Liga mit den interessantesten Talenten. Das sieht man ja immer wieder. Das haben wir ja auch schon im Rasenfunk thematisiert. Das haben wir ja auch schon in diesem Segment so ein bisschen anklingen lassen. Jetzt weiß ich allerdings nicht so ganz, wie ich jetzt die Brücke bauen kann von Talenten zu Bas Dost, der nämlich der Zweite ist in der Torjägerliste der portugiesischen Liga. Und wo spielt er bei Sporting? Er hat 14 Treffer, also er ist quasi der Jäger von Haris Seferovic. Das hätte man sich früher auch so nicht denken können. Sporting haben wir jetzt immer wieder so nebenher schon erwähnt. Drei Punkte Rückstand auf Tabellenplatz 3, schon acht Punkte Rückstand auf 2 und 10 auf 1. Also sprich, da wird nach ganz weit oben hin nicht mehr so viel gehen. Woran hackt es denn bei Sporting?
Ja, also erstmal, jetzt finde ich, wenn du Bas Dost erwähnt, jetzt habe ich nämlich gerade bei Braga Diego Sousa unterschlagen. Der hat nämlich auch 14 Tore.
Ja, stimmt.
Und das ist für seine Verhältnisse auch eine sehr, sehr gute Saison. Genau, also er und Bas Dost sind so die, die da Seferovic verfolgen in der Toioga-Liste. Also das sind schon drei, drei auch echt gute Stürmer zu Sporting. Klar, sie müssten nominell auf jeden Fall die Nummer 3 sein, auch natürlich vom Gesamtmannschaftswert her. Aber diese schwächelnde Form in dieser Saison ist erklärbar. Da gibt es eine sehr, sehr schöne, lange Trainergeschichte, die ich dir jetzt dazu erzählen kann.
Okay, jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Ja, pass auf, kannst dich festhalten. Das hat Hasfausche-Ausmaße.
Ui, da müsste man ein Tribüngespräch daraus machen.
Genau, der aktuelle Trainer Marcel Keizer ist der vierte in dieser Saison. Deswegen die Hasfauschen-Ausmaße. Und diese ganze Posse um die Trainer bei Sporting begann eigentlich schon im Sommer. Denn da wurde der Vertrag von Jorge Jesus aufgelöst, in beiderseitigem Einvernehmen. Der wollte, glaube ich, zu irgendeinem arabischen Club. Ich kann es jetzt nicht mehr genau sagen. Jedenfalls kam dann der neue Trainer Mihailović. Der war für sagen und schreiben neun Tage im Amt. Das hat den ganz einfachen Grund, dass der alte Präsident de Carvallo ihn geholt hatte. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel du damit bekommen hast. Das muss ein Präsident gewesen sein, der alles abgerissen hat. Der hat sich mit jeglichen Spielern angelegt. Der hat da immer einen kompletten Alleingang gemacht, gemacht, was er wollte quasi. Irgendwann haben sie es dann mal übers Herz gebracht und ihn gefeuert. Folgerichtig, weil er ja den Trainer geholt hatte, Mihailović, musste der auch wieder gehen. Auf Mihailović folgte dann im Juli José Pesero. Der war von 2004 bis 2005 schon mal in Amt. Der wurde dann aber nach acht Spieltagen schon wieder entlassen, obwohl er nur zwei Punkte Rückstand auf Porto hatte. Und dann hatten sie...
Aber womit waren die da unzufrieden? Waren die mit der Spielart unzufrieden? Gab es da irgendwie Nebengeschichten? Klar, du kannst jetzt einfach sagen, die sind wieder HSV. Lieber HSV-Fans da draußen, die sich jetzt alle ärgern, der Marc ist dem HSV sehr nahe.
Die können das ab, die sind abgehärtet.
Ja, muss er irgendwie. Aber kannst du mir noch kurz sagen, das mit Mikhailović, das verstehe ich ja. Gut, neun Tage im Abend, wahrscheinlich dann wenigstens eine gute Abfindung dafür bekommen, da wird der Schnitt dann gut gewesen sein. Aber Pesero, der eben, ja, also Sporting hatte einen ganz guten Start, du hast es ja gesagt, mit dem Zwei-Punkten-Rückstand, woran lag es dann, dass er gehen musste?
Jetzt muss ich dir sagen, ich habe den Anfang der Liga NOS noch nicht so intensiv verfolgt. Da habe ich das noch nicht für Sport Digital gemacht. Das heißt, im Einzelnen kann ich dir das jetzt nicht sagen, aber ich kann mir das schon sehr gut vorstellen. Man sieht ja an dieser ganzen Geschichte, was für ein Chaos-Club Sporting ja in gewisser Weise ist. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass da einfach sehr, sehr schnell, ja, Unzufriedenheit herrscht. Ob es jetzt an der Spielart lag oder ansonstigen drin, vielleicht ist mit Pesero da auch nicht alles gut gelaufen, ich weiß es nicht. Jedenfalls, er wurde ja relativ schnell wieder gegangen. Und um diese Geschichte weiter zu erzählen, der nächste Trainer war dann der Interimsträger-Trainer Thiago Fernandes, der dritte Trainer. Und nachdem sie dann sich entschieden haben, für Marcel Keizer, der seit November im Amt und unter ihm, läuft es jetzt auch eher mäßig. Aber das ist ja auch irgendwie verständlich, wenn du vier Trainer in einer Saison hast, das ist ja auch für eine Mannschaft nicht so einfach. Sie haben jetzt unter ihm acht Siege geholt, drei unentschiedene Niederlagen, das ist auch okay. Aber es ist eben, wie gesagt, nominell müsste da mehr gehen bei Sporting, aber das liegt, glaube ich, in diesen Gründen, die wir genannt haben. Und man muss auch noch dazu sagen, sie haben auch echt viele Abgänge im Sommer gehabt, was auch wiederum zum großen Teil mit dem Ex-Präsidenten de Cavaio zu tun hat, der sich eben vor allem auch zum Beispiel mit seinem fast namensfetter William Cavaio, die man hört, überworfen hat. Der ist für 20 Millionen Zubetis gegangen. Rui Patricio haben sie verloren für 18 Millionen an die Wolves in England. Und Gale John Martins, auch ein unglaublich guter Spieler, einer der Leistungsträger, ablösefrei zu Atletico. Das sind alles so ein paar Gründe, wie man eben für diese Situation, in der sich Sporting diese Saison befindet, finden kann.
Marcel Keizer, mir war er vorher kein Begriff, ist ein Niederländer, der unter anderem bei Ajax auch mal Trainer war, allerdings auch jetzt nicht besonders lange. Bei niederländischen Trainern erwartet man immer so einen gewissen Spielstil, Positionsspiel, sehr breit angelegt, sehr passintensiv. Spieler sollen polyvalent sein, auch gerne mal Rollen tauschen. Ist denn so auch der Fußball von Sporting? Denn dann gucke ich es mir mal an, vielleicht.
Ja, kann man schon so sagen. Aber auch bei Sporting geht auch viel über die individuelle Qualität. Da ist vor allem Bruno Fernandes zu nennen, der ja alles überragt. Der hat 36 Torbeteiligungen in dieser Saison. Es gibt ja auch schon Gerüchte von jeglichen Vereinen. Menyoo, Chelsea, Liverpool, Milan, die sollen alle an ihm dran sein. Menyoo, dem Vernehmen nach, der größte Interessent. Schmerzgrenze läge wohl bei 45 Millionen Euro. Und dazu dann natürlich Bas Dost. Und mit Acuña und Quattish haben sie auch noch zwei richtig gute Verteidiger hinten drin. Auf internationalem Niveau. Also eigentlich müsste Sporting den ersten beiden Konkurrenz machen. Aber wie gesagt, diese Unruhe sorgt dann irgendwie dafür, dass das auch auf dem Platz dann nicht immer die Top-Leistungen gibt.
Und Bruno Fernandes, das ist ja wirklich interessant. Der hat ja schon bei Udinese gespielt. Und bei Sampdoria ist jetzt, ich glaube, 24 Jahre alt. Und jetzt auf einmal scheint es so, als habe er seinen Durchbruch. Also du hast dir die Zahlen genannt, die sind Wahnsinn. Die Gerüchte hat man ja vielleicht auch schon bis hier nach Deutschland gehört, dass da wirklich viele Vereine dran zu sein scheinen. Interessante Karriere, mal anders als so ein 21-jähriger Brasilianer, der halt voll einschlägt.
Ja, also gut, eine Entwicklung muss ja nicht immer heißen, dass man wie ein Imba P mit 19 schon auf Weltklassenniveau spielt. Nee, er hat jetzt über mehrere Jahre immer konstant seine Leistung gesteigert. Und jetzt in dieser Saison ist er natürlich schon in gewisser Weise explodiert. Also das ist schon echt herausragend, was er macht. Auch in allen Facetten, die so ein offensiver Middelsfeldspieler wie er haben muss. Und auch im Taktischen ist das gut, was er macht. Und deswegen, ja, also da kann man auch sehr, sehr gespannt sein. Also da allgemein aus Portugal, da werden wir einige Spieler noch hervortretend sehen. Wir haben sie jetzt auch zum großen Teil schon genannt. Und das macht eben so ein bisschen, was ich auch schon gesagt habe, den Reiz dieser Liga aus, dass du vor allem diese großen Talente verfolgen kannst. Und dann irgendwann hoffentlich dann auch mal auf der ganz großen internationalen Bühne siehst.
Apropos Reiz dieser Liga, da hätte ich ja neben den großen 4, die wir jetzt besprochen haben, auch noch den Abstiegskampf mit genannt. Denn der beginnt ja je nachdem, wie weit man es definieren will. Aber man könnte sagen ab Platz 9, da liegt Rio Ave mit 28 Punkten. Und auf Platz 17 liegt mit Chavez eine Mannschaft mit 20 Punkten. Das heißt, das sind 8 Punkte zwischen Platz 17 bis zu Platz 9. Und die Plätze 16, 17 und 18 müssen in die Abstiegsrelegation. Du hast vorhin schon so ein bisschen angedeutet, es gibt noch ein paar interessante Mannschaften, die nicht zu den üblichen Verdächtigen gehören. Da werden jetzt ja wahrscheinlich ein paar deiner Kandidaten mit dabei sein.
Ja, also ich finde auch erst mal müsste man noch, also diese Abstiegskampf, der fängt ja eigentlich fast schon bei Platz 8 an. Das ist ja Wahnsinn. Zwischen Platz 8 und 16 sind nur 8 Punkte. Und auf Platz 8 steht eine Mannschaft, die aber für mich eine der Überraschungen dieser Saison ist. Das ist Santa Clara, diesen Aussteiger, und spielen die beste Saison ihrer Vereinsgeschichte. 8 Punkte Vorsprung auf einen Abstiegsplatz. Das muss man erstmal machen. Das ist schon richtig gut, was sie machen. Die haben sich im Sommer richtig gut verstärkt. Die haben von Porto Seemmanuel geholt. Der ist Topscorer bei ihnen. Patrick von Benfica. Also richtig gute Einkäufe gemacht und zeigen sehr stabile Leistungen bei der gesamten Saison. Sowohl defensiv als auch offensiv. Das schlägt sich dann auch im Torverhältnis nieder, was 32 zu 32 ist. Bei denen fängt es theoretisch an, aber ich würde aufgrund ihrer Leistungen sagen, dass die da gar nicht mehr reinrutschen. Das sieht einfach insgesamt viel zu stabil aus. Allerdings muss man dazu sagen, sie haben jetzt auch noch Porto, Benfica und Sporting vor der Brust. Deswegen ein schweres Restprogramm. Ansonsten ist es tatsächlich dahinter, hast du so ein paar Mannschaften, die vom Kader her auch eigentlich zu gut für den Abstiegskampf sein müssten. Rio Ave, Portimone Enze, das sind so Mannschaften, die man da nennen muss.
Portimone Enze, wollen die irgendwann noch mal gewinnen aus den letzten sechs Spielen, die ich hier sehe, fünf Niederlagen? Da muss es ja auch einen interessanten Saisonverlauf gegeben haben, wenn die jetzt auf Platz 10 liegen.
Ja, die waren zwischenzeitlich auch mal fünfter. Deswegen wird das auch spannend zu sehen. Wenn du erst mal in so einen Strudel reingeredet bist, gegen Ende der Saison, das ist durchaus nicht ungefährlich. Allerdings, Portimone Enze mit Spielern wie Jackson Martinez und auch Paulinho, der vor der Saison von Porto gekommen ist, eigentlich genug Qualität. Sie haben jetzt auch die letzten Jahre, sie sind ja auch selber erst 2017 aufgestiegen, sind sie zweimal auf Platz 10 gelandet. Da stehen sie jetzt auch und ich glaube, dass sie da auch am Ende bleiben werden. Ich traue ihnen schon zu, dass sie sich da auch jetzt, die letzten Spieler, dass sie sich da daraus befreien. Ansonsten auch interessant, Rio Aaf, habe ich ja gerade schon angesprochen, mit Spielern wie Colin Traau, Denderson Galeno, Bruno Moreira, das sind schon ein paar Namen, die man durchaus kennt. Auch interessant, der Saisonverlauf, sind Furios gestartet, zwischenzeitlich vierter gewesen, dann grauenhaften Herbst gehabt, wo sie fast alles verloren haben. Jetzt sind sie dann wieder ein bisschen besser gewesen, jetzt wieder schlechter. Das ist so eine Mannschaft, die irgendwie ein bisschen anfällig ist für Krisen. Auch da müssen sie aufpassen, nicht in einen Stuhl zu geraten. Jetzt haben sie speziell gegen Chaves und National und Abes drei direkte Duelle. Die müssen natürlich gewonnen werden, weil auch sie, Rio Aaf, noch gegen Sporting, Porto und Benfica spielt. Aber ich glaube, dass Rio Aaf und Portimonez das schon schaffen werden. Am Ende wird sich das wahrscheinlich entscheiden zwischen anderen Teams. Ich würde jetzt mal Fadenza als Letzten rausnehmen, die haben seit 22 Spielen nicht mehr gewonnen. Also Wahnsinn. Und die Schießbude der Liga würde ich tatsächlich schon mal mit rausnehmen. Die Plätze 16 und 17 werden sich entscheiden zwischen Nacional, Havish, Stubal, Malitimo und Tondela. Das sind so die, die ich da reinziehen würde.
Also die, die auch jetzt auf den Plätzen 12 bis 16 dann eben liegen, plus 17 eben noch genauer, 16 und 17, hast du ja gesagt. Gibt es da eine Mannschaft, wo es besonders überraschend ist, dass sie da unten reingerutscht ist?
Ich würde jetzt bei keiner sagen, dass es besonders überraschend ist. Stubal könnte man vielleicht noch sagen. Also es sind eigentlich alles Mannschaften, die so ungefähr sich auch marktwerttechnisch auf dem selben Niveau befinden. Wobei es ganz stimmt, das habe ich jetzt fast unterschlagen. Aves, die sind letztes Jahr sensationell Pokalsieger geworden. Die haben gerade 2-1 gegen Sporting gewonnen. Zu denen gibt es auch eine interessante Geschichte. Sie sind, weil sie ihre Unterlagen für die Europa League bei der UEFA nicht rechtzeitig eingereicht haben. Nicht in der Europa League dieses Jahr. Wobei sie da wahrscheinlich auch nicht allzu weit gekommen wären. Weil das auch einfach qualitativ dann eigentlich nicht reicht. Ja, deswegen, also zwischen diesen 5 das einzuschätzen, ist nicht einfach. Ich würde aber sagen, von De La Chavis und Maritimo machen das dann unter sich aus 16 und 17. Weil ich glaube, dass vor allem Stubal zum Beispiel dann doch noch individuell stärker ist. Sie haben mit John D'Acadies einen richtig interessanten Mann. Hat 6 Tore gemacht, davon jetzt aber 4 in den letzten 7. Ich habe glaube ich noch nie einen Spieler gesehen, der so große Schritte macht. Also der ist unfassbar schnell. Aber ein sehr interessanter Mann, technisch richtig gut, starken Abschluss. Also das ist so ein bisschen die Hoffnung bei Stubal. Und ich glaube auch schon, dass der da einige Kohlen aus dem Feuer holen kann für sie. Zwischen den anderen Spielen, Mannschaften meine ich, ist es echt schwer zu sagen. Also da bewegt sie sich schon auf einem Niveau ungefähr.
Ich muss sagen, du hast mich mit Avic jetzt ein bisschen angefixt. Über die würde ich gerne kurz noch sprechen. Wenn man auf so etwas wie die Transfermarkt-Rankings, auf transfermarkt.de was gibt, dann fällt auf, Avic mit einem Gesamtmarktwert von 9,85 Millionen Euro des kompletten Kaders, weit abgeschlagen am Ende der Liga. Und trotzdem eben letztes Jahr diesen Pokalsieg geholt gegen Sporting. Sie sind aufgestiegen in der Saison 2016, 2017. Also sind jetzt seit zwei Jahren mit dabei. Und was mich total umhaut, die sind die Mannschaft, die die fünftmeisten Schüsse aufs gegnerische Tor abgibt. Das sind Dinge, die nicht zusammenpassen. Kannst du mir erklären, wie Avic das erreicht? Hast du dafür genügend Einblicke?
Ich kann es so nach den Spielen, die ich jetzt... Ich sehe es dann auch immer nur in der Zulampe.
Ja klar, du kannst ja nicht alle.
Genau, aber man kann schon bei denen sehen, dass es eine Mannschaft, die unfassbar über die Geschlossenheit kommt, das müssen sie. Logischerweise, du hast es gerade angesprochen, weil es einen Gesamtmarktwert von gerade mal neun Millionen ist. Das ist ja unglaublich eigentlich. Ich glaube, sie haben nicht mal einen Spieler, der über eine Million Marktwert hat. Carlos Ponck sehe ich gerade, der hat eine Million Marktwert. Aber ansonsten... Nee, das ist, glaube ich, eine Mannschaft, die einfach über ihre Geschlossenheit kommt. Ja, die erspielen sich schon immer ihre Chancen und stehen auch defensiv gar nicht mal so schlecht. Deswegen habe ich sie auch jetzt gar nicht genannt unter den drei Mannschaften, die es dann doch letztendlich unter sich ausmachen werden bei den letzten zwei zu vergebenden Abstiegsplätzen. Also, ja, das... Sie haben jetzt auch gerade ein wichtiges, wichtiges Sieg geholt im direkten Duell gegen Boavista. Haben dadurch vielleicht auch ein bisschen die Psychologie auf ihrer Seite, weil sie wissen, dass sie gegen die direkten Konkurrenten gewonnen und gewinnen können.
Aber haben auch den Trainer gewechselt. Seit 16.01. Augusto Inácio, das ist jetzt kein Wissen, was ich vor dieser Sendung hatte, das will ich jetzt nicht behaupten, José Mota nach 44 Spielen im Amt und 356 Tagen wurde er abgelöst. Die Trainerentscheidung im Portugal muss man nicht immer nachvollziehen können von außerhalb, oder?
Da habe ich nicht genug Einblick, was diese Trainerwechsel angeht. Diese Geschichte bei Sporting ist natürlich durch die Gazetten gegangen. Ich denke mal, was die anderen Dinge angeht, das ist das tägliche Brot, was der Fußball hergibt, wenn es nicht läuft, auch bei abstiegsbedrohten Teams und Mannschaften, die auch nominell sich eher nach unten orientieren müssen. Klar, das passiert, aber bei Abesh jetzt auch speziell, das kann ich dir jetzt nicht sagen, warum sie den Trainer gewechselt haben.
Die berühmten Mechanismen des Fußballs, das ist schlimm. Sie waren zwischenzeitlich immer letzter, und dann gab es tatsächlich den Trainerwechsel, sehe ich gerade. Es wird doch dann eng damit zusammengehangen haben. Damit lässt es sich dann erklären. Ach ja, Wahnsinn. Es gäbe so viel zu lernen über diese Liga, aber ich finde, du hast uns schon tiefere Einblicke gegeben als ich es mir jemals hätte zusammen googeln können mit ganz viel Zeit. Marc, das hat großen Spaß gemacht. Sag uns unbedingt Bescheid, wenn sich der Abstiegskampf auf die letzten 12 Mannschaften ausgedehnt hat. Da müssen wir noch mal sprechen und mal gucken. Genau. Und dann gucken wir doch einfach mal, wie sich die Saison weiter in Portugal entwickelt. Vielleicht lohnt ja noch mal einen Blick. Dann würde ich mich freuen, wenn wir uns mal wieder hören. Auch wiederum sehr gerne. Man kann dir folgen als Edsportwiese auf Twitter. Das möchte ich an dieser Stelle allen Hörerinnen und Hörern ans Herz legen. Und damit endet dieser Kurzpass Nummer 219, ist es glaube ich, nein, 120. Entschuldigung, ich war gerade bei den Schlusskonferenzen verrückt. Es wird Zeit, hier den Schlussstrich zu ziehen. Vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, lasst uns Feedback da unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder in allen sozialen Netzwerken eurer Wahl. Und dann hören wir uns schon relativ bald wieder. Ihr könnt euch freuen, der nächste Kurzpass wird auch toll. Bis dahin habt ihr eine gute Zeit, macht's gut, ciao!